Let's start with this first number line. The first shaded region down here
starts all the way out at negative infinity, and comes up through negative 9,
including negative 9. So we have negative infinity to negative 9 united with
negative 6, which is not included up through positive infinity. Written as a
compound inequality, this should be read as y is less than or equal to 9 or y is
greater than negative 6. Of course, noting that our variable here is y as shown
at the edge of the number line. For the second number line, our interval goes
from negative 4, including negative 4, through 8, which is not included. The
inequality for this would be read as negative 4 is less than or equal to z is
less than 8. We could also write this of course, using an and. Negative 4 is
less than or equal to z and z is less than 8.